[Music]
one of the things that I found out that
was sort of amazing about your history
you briefly mentioned it right before we
started you were a Marxist at one time
in your life most people will find this
hard to believe but it is true
but it's not that
unusual uh most of the leading
conservatives I thinkers of our time
time uh did not start off as
conservative you had a couple like Bill
Buckley and George will but I mean
Milton Freedman was was a was a liberal
and a
Keynesian Hayak was a
socialist Ronald Reagan was so far left
at one point the FBI was following him
so then what was your wake up to what
was wrong with that line of of thinking
uh
[Applause]
facts
do kick to the
face well you we could probably end the
interview right there fact there you go
[Applause]
yeah all right people I'm Dave Ruben
this is the Ruben report it's November
13th 2023
we are on Rumble we are still on YouTube
we are on locals tap subscribe click the
notification Bell whatever it is you do
do it if you have not if you'd like to
join us for a postgame show we'll be at
Ruben report. locals.com and as you guys
know we have launched our second show
people of the internet every Monday
through Thursday at 1 p.m. Eastern and
if you want to submit questions because
it's a call-in show where I hear from
you you hear from me it's a little back
and forth a little more integrated uh
you can join us we're only taking
questions from locals members I don't
know if you know this but there's some
crazy people on the internet I don't
really want to hear from them we want to
hear from our locals members so Ruben
report. locals.com the theme on this
Monday is that the woke mind virus is
basically communism Marxism
socialism collectivism rebranded right
it's taken all the collectivist ideas of
the past it's added a dash of new found
RAC ISM and it's added some weird gender
stuff and it has to its credit uh
destroyed so much of what western
liberal societies are supposed to stand
for which is you know the individual
limited government kind of living life
as you see fit kind of that good stuff
that was the dream of humanity for
thousands and thousands of years
something that the United States of
America did better than any country in
the history of the world and that seems
to be kind of flitting away right in
front of our eyes uh so we're going to
look at uh what these communist Marxist
wster Hamas supporting wack jobs uh have
brought Across America and across Europe
and uh we're going to try to give you
some solutions because I actually do
think there is a way to fight back uh
before we get to that let me talk to you
guys about my Patriot Supply guys it's
clear the unthinkable is here our most
trusted institutions now deceive us
every single day something is clearly
wrong and time is short to become more
self-reliant and secure for the future
of your family act today with my Patriot
Supply my Patriot Supply is the
country's largest preparedness company
and they're more than equipped to stock
your shelves their best-selling
three-month emergency food kit provides
delicious breakfast breakfast lunches
and dinners that last up to 25 years in
storage these kits provide over 2,000
calories every day and are simple to
prepare just to add water and heat then
eat make sure every member of your
family has a 3month food kit for my
Patriot Supply go now to my special
website prepare withth ruben.com order
by 300 p.m. and your food kits ship fast
on the same day with free shipping it's
best to have emergency food and not need
it than to need it and not have it
that's prepare withth ruben.com prepare
with ruben.com and now back to me so yes
uh the silver lining of the last five
weeks of abject insanity and and the
barbarism Not only that took place in
Israel but the that we're seeing really
across every Western City it it it's so
freaking profoundly evil we all know
that well you watching this know that
let's put it that way uh but there is a
silver lining and the Silver Lining is
that some people are starting to wake up
putting babies in ovens and raping women
in front of their husbands and all of
that stuff actually pushed a certain set
of people to the Limit and and maybe
they are coming around so I want to
start Today's Show uh with Elon Musk he
was on Lex freedman's podcast and you
know Elon over the last couple years uh
has been one of the people that very
publicly kind of like me years ago and
many people before me Ronald Reagan for
example and Milton Freedman and many
others uh was a lefty at one point of in
his life a liberal whatever you want to
call it and then started waking up and
started seeing what was actually going
on and Elon has done that very publicly
uh and then of course he bought Twitter
which allowed us to discuss that stuff
publicly without the threat of
censorship at least not the way the
government was censoring us before hand
on Twitter uh and he's been very
outspoken about all this so here's Elon
talking about the woke mind virus on Lex
fredman over the past year or so since
since purchasing X you've become more
political is there a part of you that
regrets that have I in this
battle
to um sort of counter way the the woke
that comes from yeah I guess if you
consider fighting the woke mind virus
which I consider to be a civilizational
threat to be political then yes so
basically going into the the battle the
battleground of
politics is there part of you there
agress yes I don't know if this is
necessarily sort of one candidate or
another candidate but it's um I'm
generally against things that are anti-
meritocratic uh or where there's an
attempt to suppress
discussion um where even discussing a
topic is you know not
allowed um The W Bine virus is communism
rebranded woke mind virus is communist
communism rebranded now the reason I
wanted to start with that clip is
because it's interesting having met Elon
a couple times and even in the subtext
of that clip right there he's not
particularly political he has said that
in his life he when he voted he usually
voted for Democrats he's voted I think
for one Republican ever it was for the
Myra Flores down in Texas since he's
moved down to Austin because he like
many others including Joe Rogan uh fled
California for the greener pastures of
Texas and he was concerned about the IL
illegal immigration situation down there
but he's not a particularly political
person he doesn't I well he certainly
doesn't consider himself a Democrat
anymore but he definitely doesn't
consider himself a republican he's tried
to open up the conversation for people
and what he is concerned about is the
destruction of meritocracy he's
concerned that people who work hard who
have a certain skill who want to
accomplish something and build things
that they will not be able to because
what have we traded meritocracy in for
what have we traded the idea of go out
and get yours we've traded it in for Dei
right diversity equity and inclusion
that we will rejigger the system so that
everyone will end up in the same spot
which is deeply deeply anti-American but
it is the set of ideas that the
Democrats and the corporate media and
virtually all of our Industries and
institutions have been based on right
even when they were rolling out coid
vaccines remember they wanted equity in
Co vaccines so more black people would
get Co vaccines which in retrospect may
be not the best idea if you cared about
black people but anyway this idea of
removing you work hard you have skills
go get yours replacing that with we will
change things around artificially so
that we'll all end up in the same spot
it's deeply anti-American but it's
deeply embedded in all of our power
structures right now so I want to show
you a video from the last couple days
this is Vice President Lord helpus Cala
Harris uh talking about Dei and the
economy we are not afraid to discuss
diversity and equity and inclusion
understanding that that is part of how
we will create a stronger economy and a
stronger Nation look at her with so many
words no no no no it will not do any of
those things it's woke communism what
you are trying to usher in just as Elon
Musk is pointing out diversity well
diversity in and of itself the idea that
you might live in a community with some
black people and some Asian people and
some white people and some Jews and some
Muslims okay that's just fine but it's
not good in and of itself if all of
these people have competing interest and
some are born to hate others that would
be a problem right would you want a
diverse community of say Nazis and
Communists and socialists that might not
really be great and what they really
don't want more than anything else is
diversity of thought when she talks
about diversity meaning you will all
believe what we believe that's not
really diversity Equity of course is
very different than equality Equity is
that we will all end up in the same
place that's the that's like the most
basic communist idea ever of course what
they don't tell you is that the elites
will live up here they'll be super super
rich right the oligarchs of Russia the
Elite Class of China in communist places
they will all live up here you guys will
all have well pretty much nothing but
you'll be able to survive is as long as
you don't talk bad about us and
inclusion the the idea of inclusion well
I guess it sort of sounds good but do
you want to include everyone into
everything that you do when you have a
dinner party at your house do you invite
everyone and just leave your door open
and say everyone is welcome to come here
or should we be be Discerning in who is
actually included when we're talking
about inclusion I think you know the
answer but here's a bit more from Camala
Harris on over equality and just
remember this is the most deeply
anti-American anti- capitalism anti uh
our founding documents and the
principles of this country idea you
could possibly have go to that extent
yes we do talk about Equity we actually
believe it is a good
principle in spite what some so-called
leaders might try to suggest we are
proud of the fact that Equity is one of
our gr guiding principles proud of the
fact that we understand equality is
important but not everybody starts out
on the same
base so it sounds like it might be right
everyone gets an equal share and then
they should compete and the best thing
will win but that assumes everyone
starts out on the same base Equity takes
into account that that may not be the
case he's evil it's like you know what I
don't want to go full on evil it's a
Monday it's Monday morning I'm not she's
just dumb like she's just dumb I
actually believe she said that thinking
it means something there are people that
are more evil I would say Barack Obama
let's say is more evil there are
definitely more you know the Hamas
caucus types are more evil I actually
think she believes what she's saying as
if it's good which not that that you
know the road to hell is paid with good
intentions um but yes it is true that
equality which is what we have here in
America you can't have laws that
discriminate against any particular
person because based on immutable
characteristics or religion or that sort
of thing uh yes everyone does start off
at different things some people are born
really rich and they screw it up they
get hooked on drugs they waste the money
they blow family fortunes some people
come from nothing and they become
billionaires and we love those stories
it is literally literally impossible to
have everyone start at the same place
unless you kill an awful lot of people
and then whoever you have left you
better start making sure they don't
think for themselves because then they
might start wanting to do something
that's more in their own interest and
their family's interest and their local
community's interest so it is deeply
dangerous and yet we have let this in
the day before the election that brought
us the elderly man pretending to be
president and that dard right there she
posted Camala Harris posted a cartoon on
her Twitter feed talking about how the
future of America should be Equity not
equality she literally told us communism
is what we believe in and Biden is just
the vessel ushering it in and she again
I think she actually believes what she's
saying not in a malicious way than there
are the actual uh malicious people um
the opposite guys of woke communism the
idea that Elon is worried about the the
very notion that Kamal Harris is pushing
there is a mraic nationalism right the
idea that you have a country it has some
culture it has say borders it's based on
Liberty Liberty and individual rights
none of these things are that fancy by
the way these are the things that we
have had patriotism could be a part of
it right uh working hard and getting
ahead keeping more of what you earn
these are like basic simple things that
we all know are better they we all know
are the the the keys to unlocking the
life that you want to live except we are
now governed by a set of people that
really want to push something uh much
more dangerous on us um so let's shift a
little bit because one of the things
that they have been trying desperately
to do is scare us from all of the people
who've been a little more into freedom
and for my criticisms of Donald Trump
over the last couple months he is
certainly way more into freedom than any
of these Lefty Democrats so what do they
have to do well they have to scare the
hell out of you when it comes to Donald
Trump he's a racist he's a white
supremacist the Russians installed him
you know the drill but it's still
continuing right now so here's a video
from the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC it's Jen saki that's
right uh with representative Jamie Rasin
and they are very concerned if Donald
Trump becomes president again because he
might start doing scary stuff let's
freak the people out go you have thought
a lot about Donald Trump and you have
studied him a lot you've uh been so
involved in holding him accountable when
he said this week if they're beating me
go down and indict them and some of the
uh pronouncements he's made over the
weekend I've heard that as kind of his
authoritarian impulses getting worse how
do you hear them well the role of the
government in his view is to advance his
political fortunes and Destroy his
political en enemies so what would a
second term look like it would look a
lot like Vladimir Putin in Russia it
would look a lot like Victor Orban in
Hungary illiberal democracy meaning
democracy without rights or Liberties or
respect for the uh due process system
the rule of
law Monday I just have to keep reminding
myself it's Monday um okay everything
Rasin just said there is idiotic and and
the Democrats and and Biden have far
more to do with authoritarianism
remember mandates remember locking
people in their houses remember all that
stuff you're going to be forced to be
jabbed or you can't have a job we're
going to fire you all that kind of stuff
uh remember when they were sick in the
FBI on parents who wanted to know if
their children were being misgendered at
schools yeah that was the Democrats also
they're very concerned about this Victor
orbon in Hungary we were in Hungary here
I am with Victor orbon very scary man uh
yes he is the prime minister of Hungary
and I spent about a half hour with him
that's at the prime minister's office
that's the danu river behind us it was
absolutely glorious beautiful day there
and I spent a half hour with this guy
and you know what he talked about I love
my country I don't know what accident
that was but that's basically what he
said repeatedly I love my country
Hungary is for hungarians we don't want
all the immigrants here what is that
accent that's more I'm doing a little
Russian that's like one of the bad guys
in Air Force One with Harrison
Ford you get it he just cared about his
people and his country and by the way
the streets were clean the people were
pleasant uh there's about a 100,000 Jews
that still live in Hungary I think in
Budapest itself and they are living
peacefully and prosperously uh which is
a far cry from what's happening right
now to the Jews of London and in some of
the other places in Europe here's a
little video of what's going on in
Budapest this is the place that Jamie
Raskin and Jen saki are very afraid
of
[Music]
all right so this might feel a little
heavy-handed what I'm doing today but I
I think it's really really important
right now and it's getting increasingly
important especially when I get to the
second half of the show to understand
that if if Western societies are going
to continue that we are going to have to
start defending ourselves so when they
tell you that Victor Orban is evil
because he doesn't want his country
invaded is it that he's evil or that he
cares about the people of Hungary when
they tell you that the president of
Poland is now evil because he doesn't
want a massive migration is it again
because he's racist or he cares about
Polish people and then when you contrast
that to what has happened in say Germany
and France and England like did those
people who let in millions of people who
didn't care about their culture didn't
care about their Norms didn't care about
their free speech or their history of
their country were they non it was it
was so great that they were non-racist
that they let all these people in to
destroy their societies does that make
them better
somehow so when they go after the people
that are actually trying to somehow
roughly at least talk about what the
actual issues are of the day know that
it's the people on MSNBC and New York
Times in Washington Post that they're
the bad guys here let's continue with
Jen saki because now she's warning us
what evil Donald Trump might do if he
gets that second ter and yet the hand
ringing and cocktail party speculation
about an alternative to Joe Biden is
continuing will continue guess what Joe
Biden isn't perfect no candidate is by
the way but we have to understand what
the alternative is here if elected to a
second term Donald Trump would prosecute
anyone he deems an enemy unleash troops
on protesters and essentially unravel
the rule of law as we know it and this
time he plans to line his administration
with people who will actually help him
do it but sure Joe Biden is three years
older and occasionally trips over things
look there's a lot to be concerned about
right now when it comes to a second
Trump term the speeches are getting much
more disturbing and much more unhinged
and we all hear it that way by the way
again you guys know I've been critical
of trump I'm not supporting Trump right
now I think there's a much better choice
on the Republic ins side in Ronda santis
I think that's fairly obvious and I
think a lot of people are going to be
shocked in Iowa but this endless this
hand ringing this fear mongering this
craziness from by the way a woman who is
now thought of as a journalist on MSNBC
who worked for Joe Biden right she was
the press secretary for Joe Biden and
now she's analyzing the news on msnb see
like the whole thing is just an
absolute farce but what they fear
actually is not that Donald Trump is
going to jail his political opponents
which is much more in line with what
they would like to do and it's not that
he's going to destroy the other
political party or just whatever the
craziness of the day is with these
people it's not any of that right what
it really is is that he or actually any
Republican might start doing some things
that are a little more pro-american
Amica and these people are not
interested in America so now I want to
show you a clip from Real Time with Bill
Maher on Friday night uh Jordan Peterson
have you heard of this guy he was on
real time they did a whole bunch on
gender then they got into the Middle
East and they got into Trump and what's
going on with the Democrats and and a
bunch more Jordan Jordan was just
spectacular I highly recommend you watch
the the full panel on that it's
interesting because Jordan really uh he
makes Bill sort of better because you
can see a lot of times where Bill sort
of defaults back into his kind of like
Lefty liberal posturing and Jordan kind
of pushes him to rise up a little bit
more uh but they got into it about
Israel and what's going on and how the
Democrats have gone off the deep end and
Jordan related that back to well maybe
it has a little something to do with
their unhinged hatred of trump and the
things that he actually accomplished I
think you can lay a fair bit of what
happened in Israel on Biden's
plate because I I can explain that I
guess I should
Bill I know I know that Saudis were hot
to sign the Abraham Accords 2 years ago
and I have a sneak more than a sneaking
suspicion that the reason they weren't
pursued more assiduously because it
would have meant giving Trump some
credit for something that happened
during his term and I know that the
Iranians are fomenting descent in
Palestine through Hamas to pressure the
Jews into doing something so you know
what would you call it military that'll
split the Arab world and I think you can
put a fair bit at that of that at the
feet of the Democrats who didn't bring
Saudi Arabia into the Abraham Accords
when they could have two years ago and I
do think that's because they wouldn't
give Trump any credit for what he
accomplished with the Abraham Accords
and I do think that's why we're in the
position we're in right now and you know
Biden also alienated the sis the first
time that he went to talk to them and
pushed them into the arms of China and
even despite that the Saudis are still
lurking in the background trying to
ensure that the abrahamic cords won't
fold and so that's not good that was a
big mistake we a chance there to make
peace and the Saudis were behind the
abrahamic courts so so yes please I'm
surprised to learn that Biden has
started two Wars in Ukraine and in
Israel because I was thinking it was
Putin and Hamas but I
gu tell him I'm I'm with you okay so we
left that little ridiculous Applause
line in from that woman she's a New York
Times chick in the red and she's just
like it doesn't matter like she's just
an avatar for like the sort of do
nothing liberal blah BL blah blah blah
Jordan say Jordan didn't say that Biden
started those Wars he said a certain
amount of blame is to be on Biden and
the Democrats and then he laid out a
rather compelling argument for that
which we all know is true do you
remember what was it 10 days might have
been eight or or even maybe a week
before uh October 7th before those Hamas
attacks when everyone knew Netanyahu
basically said it we've got the deal
with Saudi Arabia like it was going to
completely change the face of the Middle
East and the Democrats and this
Administration and it's Obama it's not
Biden Biden is just a body they do not
want peace in the Middle East right they
don't want a truly integrated Middle
East and they certainly don't want that
if that means Trump is going to get
credit for it and Trump damn well
deserves credit for it remember when
Trump moved the embassy from Tel Aviv
the isra the American Embassy in Israel
from Tel Aviv to their actual capital in
Jerusalem and everyone said all hell is
going to break loose and it's going to
be World War I and it was nothing and
then suddenly all these peace deals got
signed peace in the Middle East used to
be something everyone was for right now
the woke left is for you know a genocide
and everything else but okay let's put
that aside for a second but the point is
these people have gone so woke and so
caught up in this communist collectivist
lunacy that they would gladly erase
anything good done by the non-woke so
they would gladly Shred the Abraham
Accords and they will gladly let
terrorists and their own and their
sympathizers into all of our countes so
now let's dive into uh what's been going
on across Western civilizations uh this
past weekend and it's a and it's a
Confluence of I would say climate
communism and multiculturalism and if
you stew them up enough it's it's pretty
freaking toxic check this out this is
Midtown New York City Lexington Avenue
right by Grand Central Station this is
this weekend and watch these pramas
protesters and again do not tell me they
are not pro Hamas because there is
nobody out there condemning Hamas and
and nobody would dare condemn Hamas out
there check out these Pro Hamas
protesters tearing down an American flag
climbing up on the flag pole you can see
it you'll see that put the Palestinian
flag there oh and note the police
officers watching them do
it
[Applause]
[Music]
what you saw there were about 30 police
officers watching a man climb the post
rip down the American flag replace it
with the Palestinian flag that is
illegal
that is a crime and they let them do it
so either all of those police officers
should be fired for not doing their job
or the police chief is telling them to
not do their job in which case he should
be fired and if he's telling them not to
do their job because he's getting some
message from mayor Adams or whoever else
is on the way up the chain then they all
should be fired but if you live in New
York City you simply have to know the
police will not do their job there and
if they will not stop someone from
climbing up on public property and
desecrating the flag of the United
States what else won't they do what else
when when these crazed lunatics when
they start marching specifically through
Jewish communities which they're doing
in other parts of the world right now
they've been doing it in Montreal
they're doing it in Australia they've
been doing it in London uh and they
start you know breaking uh Windows of
Jewish stores or whatever it might be
and it won't just be Jewish stores it'll
be it'll be any place that there is any
coexistence or decency when they start
doing that will the police do anything
then what is it that the police are
doing but we live in a society where I
suppose these people you know somehow
the Palestinians are oppressed and that
somehow is connected to the oppression
of the guy climbing up the pole so we
shouldn't do anything about him but who
else is oppressed it's the climate
people because they need climate Justice
and this is this is really the video of
the day this is so spectacular so Greta
thunberg who is a climate hoe okay
she she uh she's G a speech about
climate that's what she does but you
know in this intersectional cacophony of
insanity she has now combined this with
oppression and they've combined this
with Gaza and she's a big fan of Hamas
because you know Hamas loves taking
water pipes chopping up and turning them
into Rockets that's very sound for the
environment anyway she's giving a speech
at a big climate conference and she
starts going on and on about occupied
land and then some guy gets on stage to
basically tell her lady we're supposed
to be talking about the climate and
watch them fight and it's just like have
at it like this is more Moral Combat
finish him go people on the front lines
of the climate crisis have been
experiencing the firsthand consequences
of it for decades now and they have been
sounding the alarm but we have not been
listening the people in power have not
been listening I come here for a climate
demonstration not a political
[Applause]
VI this
is Cal
[Applause]
down
calm
down calm
down have at it like Let Them Fight you
know Godzilla vers King Kong Let them
fight these people like she's just she's
so profoundly awful we knew she was
profoundly awful this entire time she's
a globalist she's a communist whatever
you want to call her but she gets up
there they want to hear about climate
change and by the way guys the climate's
not coming for you everyone settle down
you're going to be okay Barack Obama
knows it that's why he has a 30 acre
estate on Martha's Vineyard on the water
right there it's going to be just fine
don't you worry about that Bill Gates
what does he have a $50 million house
right off Seattle right on the water
don't worry about them guys John kery
flying private planes all over the Earth
to make sure that you can't fly
planes and then the guy gets up there
lady what are you talking about what
does this have to do with Hamas and
occupied land and then they drag him off
the stage you people this is inter love
you love you uh anyway here are some
pramas protests in London because this
is the big Saturday thing they're doing
in London
now all right you get it it's a lot of
river to the Sea it's m the 75y year
occupation which is ironic because there
in London and of course if we were to
end the 75e occupation we would have to
bring back the British Empire I don't
know that any of them want that I don't
know that the average Brit wants it much
less much less the terrorist
sympathizers that are out there doing
that but how long can a
society hold something like this like I
can show you there were plenty of calls
for uh they were talking about how the
Nazis should finish the job like trust
me we went through 50 videos of like the
actual firing of fireworks at police
officers and all all that stuff but you
guys get it the reason I wanted to show
you that one is how long can a society
hold this position that on every weekend
let's say or or twice a week there will
be Mass protests calling for a genocide
of people halfway across the world plus
a certain amount of your own citizens
using all of the freedoms of your nation
so that you can uh basically grow
homerow your own Society within a
society like how long does that work if
you were say a a Jewish person living in
London would you want one of those
people to be your dentist
would you want one of them to be your
Uber driver do you see how this might
start actually like singing all of the
little pieces that give us connectivity
in a society and again it's not just
about the Jews if you're just an average
British citizen who is proud of their
country who knows what their history was
right so why about we show you I love
doing these little videos this is this
is London about 90 years ago I think
it's about 88 years ago
1931 uh London in 1931 tell me does this
seem better or worse than where London's
at right
[Music]
now
really like showing those videos look
that's 1931 London things were not that
spectacular right this is post World War
I post the Great Depression they're
about to enter World War II it's not
like those people had a ton of money
there was disease all sorts of problems
but notice everyone was kind of dressed
right there was some sort of cultural
cohesion on the streets uh by the way
those people had way less money than the
average person way less economic wealth
and value than the average person that
has now been imported into London that
is screaming about how evil London is or
how evil Great Britain is and how
horrible Israel is and everything else
so look what we gave up and we did this
across the West it is not just Britain
that did this we did this across the
west but occasionally we're seeing some
glimmers and and I do want to make a
point because look one of the problems
with the news for everybody and I would
include include myself in this is that
we can always show you bad things right
I always on this show I try to always
twist things into a positive fashion at
the end uh but you know the the main
issue is that good decent people don't
really get involved right and I think it
was Hannah rent who is it that said all
evil needs to flourish in essence is
good people to be silent but I but I
don't blame good people the average
person who just wants to live their life
and take their kid to a soccer game or
whatever else and then there's this like
craz and we have this now this
intersectional thing of like the genuine
like islamist Hamas supporters the
intersectional weirdos the gender queer
people the purple hair like they're all
out there they don't have much going on
for him so they're just out there and
you have your clone soldiers and
everything else but the average say
London citizen of London the average
person in New York City is not for these
protests right but the average person
doesn't know what to do in the face of
this right the average person doesn't
want to get involved because you just
kind of want to wait it out now
unfortunately I don't I don't think
that's a winning strategy overall but
but I don't want to give the illusion
that these are most people they are not
most people but they are but they are an
increasing number of minority people who
would gladly oppress the majority and
that is a huge problem because the
majority of Americans and believe it or
not the majority of the Brits and
certainly the French we're going to show
you in just a second are good decent
Freedom loving people they just don't
know what to do in the face of this
movement and and you sort of can't blame
them so we have to keep unpacking that I
think that's the best thing that we can
do but now I want to show you something
actually kind of inspiring because every
now and again a bunch of good people do
stand up so this is from Paris uh this
is France over the weekend there were
nationalists there were politicians
citizens all
marching against anti-Semitism so
marching against Hamas marching against
most of the things that we see the
marches for right now uh and by the way
uh virtually every political party in
France was there except their far-left
party didn't make it out to this uh you
will find this one interesting because
instead of tearing down French flags
well take a look for
[Music]
yourself how bizarre French flags flying
flying in France nobody desecrating a
monument or trying to burn anything down
or calling for genocide or anything just
French people standing up for other
French people and standing up for their
values
how could I show you another video of
such a thing well actually in Poland it
was uh their annual pro- nationalism
March and you might think that sounds
racist although it just means that
Polish people like Poland and they'd
like to keep it kind of Polish so here's
a bunch of Polish people celebrating
Poland you are going to see some smoke
it's not burning down of things it was
just celebratory smoke so
[Music]
[Applause]
enjoy
I don't speak Polish but I think what
they were chanting there Loosely
translates into we're polish we like
Poland it I'm pretty sure that's
pretty much what they were chanting
there notice no violence they've closed
their borders they're they're saying hey
this is our country we like it it's
pretty good could we keep it because you
know what happens you know what happens
when you let the wers in you know what
happens when you let the collectivists
and the commun un ists and the
Socialists in they start wrecking
everything which is why socialism in
every country that has ever been tried
has not only wrecked economies and
destroyed countries but killed millions
and millions of people everywhere this
experiment has ever taken root which is
why the Socialists of today often say
well real socialism has never really
happened because those were just failed
experiments the real social everyone
will be equal it's the Camala Harris
we'll all be equal at the end it's just
so freaking lovely
well you know what H what happened in
Spain uh Spain had uh some socialists
come in and start taking over their
government and the good people have just
about had it so here is an
anti-socialist protest in Spain and
you'll also notice no burning down no
calls for genocide or murder just people
standing up for their
[Music]
country
so the way I want to bring this Monday
show home I think we've laid out
something here like we can either all of
us whatever country we're in be on the
side of tearing everything down
importing people who would gladly behead
us destroy all of our rights all of
those things and and or you know kind of
just bury our heads in the sand as that
kind of moves on all of us or we could
start thinking boy are there places that
are that are doing this a little bit
better maybe maybe pollen's doing a
little bit better maybe hungary's doing
a little bit better uh maybe the Spanish
are realizing oh there's a problem here
because we've let the Socialists in so
now good people are standing up and you
really need only look at the behavior of
the protesters right do you really think
that the guys up there climbing on that
pole tearing the American flag like
think how insane that is the police just
watch them do it in New York
City like who do you think the good guys
are you you don't have to think that
hard
right there are people who are
celebrating the murder of babies the the
rape of women and the and the kidnapping
of Holocaust Survivors and then that for
the last month has Unleashed people to
be celebrating Hitler all over the all
over the globe and then there's a couple
other people whether they're the ones
just we just showed you in Paris or
elsewhere who just like oh Western
Civilization pretty good um I'm a decent
person I have a job and a family not
exactly sure how to defend this I wish
we had better politicians and better
mechanisms to save our countries and our
societies and that's what we all got to
figure out we got to figure it out I
don't have a perfect answer for it but
we got to figure it out but there are
two competing Visions right now one is
be a victim forever and when you're a
victim you will do Untold things to the
person you think is your oppressor or
you can be a Victor you can say you know
what I'm in this Society this America
this Fran it's Britain and it's a little
whatever it's not always perfect but I
can figure out ways to survive on the
margin and not just survive over time I
can figure out ways to thrive that
that's the dream of being a free human
being you could be part of it or you can
just be a pandering buffoon so now I
bring you home with this Justin Trudeau
this is just in the last couple days who
is a pandering buffoon he is a globalist
and this guy is just terrible so of all
the things going on in the world right
now you know what he's doing he's
apologizing to the
lgbtq element op mob take a look at this
this is just wild we can and must do
better for the oppression of the lesbian
gay bisexual transgender queer and TWP
communities two we
apologize on behalf of the government
Parliament and the people of
Canada we were wrong we are
sorry and we will
never let this happen
again thank you Mr
Speaker what did that g guy do to the
lesbians why did he do that to the
lesbians what did he do to the two
Spirits do you think how insane do you
realize how insane this all is like it
sounds like he's apologizing for
slaughtering two spirit people which if
you slaughter a two-p person how many
bodies does that count as the body count
on that you're going to double that
thing what is it makes no sense gay gays
have been perfectly fine in Canada get
me who's a famous gay Canadian Justin
just besides Justin Trudeau I handed you
that one I want I want a gay male
Canadian and a lesbian from Canada right
now give me gay male in Canada
who Richard fun Richard fun Fung Fung I
don't know who that is sharp Doppler
sharp Doppler John B John okay I don't
know who any of these G oh Elliot Paige
who you used to know as Ellen Paige uh I
guess is Canadian that's very exciting
so all right I'm getting a whole list of
Canadians we've never what about a
Canadian lesbian they I feel like they
would definitely have a lot feel like in
western Canada it's a little gruffer out
there Ellen pagee Ellen pagee but was
she a lesbian before she became a man
there's a sentence for yeah he's a
famous gay Canadian Oh Ellen pagee did
both so she was lesbian when she was a
chick and now she's a gay dude yes like
get a grip lady Dude any who uh you see
the point we are governed by people who
focus on all of the wrong things while
The Barbarians are at the gate by the
way there were several shootings at a
Montreal Temple this past weekend there
have been people calling for a second
Holocaust on the streets of Canada in
various different spots but he's mostly
concerned uh with apologizing to the two
spirit people so what has happened here
how did we lose the messaging how did we
lose the story well I think there's
actually a pretty clear reason for it
and uh as you guys know I was at the arc
conference Jordan Peterson's Alliance
for responsible Citi citizenship
conference in London last week and I or
the week before and I was interviewed
about what the problem is right now why
we can't do this properly why can't we
explain ourselves uh here's just a
little bite the left has a great story
it's not a true story but it's a great
story you're oppressed they're the
oppressor let's burn the thing down you
can do it easily you can do it concisely
and everything else again it's not true
but it's clear a better story is you
need to be empowered you need to be
empowered to live your life as you see F
and if you can do that if we can create
the conditions so that you could find
the work that you want to find build the
family that you want to build live in a
community that is with like-minded
people that can Thrive and and not just
survive but thrive
that's a story you guys got it and
that's what by and large the West has
done and yet for some reason we are now
if it's Kamala Harris wanting to usher
in equity if it's Justin Trudeau we're
apologizing to two spirit people and
meanwhile The Barbarians are at the gate
and actually they're in the gate already
and as Douglas Murray often says they
will be at the gate and we will be
debating what gender pronouns to call
them this is a problem uh while that
clip was being played I have been
informed that the Kids in the Hall
remember the Kids in the Hall that had
an HBO show I think in like late 80s
early 90s uh comedy troop uh they were
all gay Scott Thompson was the big star
and they are Canadian so unless the Kids
in the Hall have been exterminated I
don't think there's anything that Justin
Trudeau has to apologize for a very odd
ending to a show uh guys postgame show
coming up in just a sec Ruben report.
locals.com people of the internet will
be live at 1 p.m. uh and a couple new uh
interviews came up from the AR
conference cuz I told you we shot so
many so we're just releasing things as
they come uh Constantine kiss and Andy
no and Brett Weinstein are all up across
platforms do we have my meme Monday for
today oh it is me Monday though on the
Ruben report uh locals community so you
can check out what I posted up there we
leave you with Camala again and I'll see
everybody at the post game in a sec all
right CIA I'm kamla
Harris and when life hands you lemons
you have to expand the Supreme
Court but for real though
for real
though I hate
[Music]
it